Jill where are you where are you right
now in the world in the world in the
world yeah yeah a farm doesn't narrow it
down too much but you're on a farm I
think I can do the rest no I actually
can't I have no idea where you're from
I'm just outside of Vulcan Alberta what
which is in Canada uh uh the town is
called Vulcan the town is called Vulcan
yes it's in Southern Alberta Southern
Alberta okay and tell us about the town
of Vulcan paint a picture for us would
you so there's about 2 000 people
um and I don't know if you guys are Star
Trek fans but the town is kind of taking
on the Star Trek theme wait as in the
Vulcans that are on Star Trek wait a
minute I don't understand what you're
saying so I just thought it's just a
town called Vulcan and uh of course
Vulcan goes back to ancient mythology uh
so it doesn't necessarily have to I mean
I'd be a [ __ ] if I said oh like Star
Trek but then you turns out you're
telling me that the town is leaning into
it right and it has a Star Trek theme
yeah so there's a Starship Enterprise as
you're going like through town like a
giant statue yeah is everybody
emotionless and very logical there
a lot of people who live here think it's
weird but
I didn't grow up here my husband did
they hosted in a communal decision yeah
everybody was like yeah let's do a Star
Trek thing yeah I mean to be honest with
you I'm from Kirk Massachusetts and we
didn't do any we didn't lean into this
at all you guys are from Vulcan and you
lost your mind when you say there's a
statue of the USS Enterprise you mean
like yeah there's a how big is this
thing how big are we talking like huge
like maybe it's I don't know like 30
feet across like it's it's amazing yeah
do people there's a trek Center in town
like they'll host um they have Spock
days in the summertime what's a trexon
and people will like it's like a Star
Trek Museum like they have a few
costumes from the show wait a minute
well like I'm sorry well they say
they're costumes from the show but
they're just costumes okay they're
probably first of all yeah trust me
Spirit Halloween store yeah exactly
don't don't don't ask too many questions
about those costumes this is
unbelievable to me that a town has
surrendered its dignity like this this
is I mean this is absolutely incredible
yeah so they have a Spock days in town
so there'll be Klingons you know walking
down the street and but also there's a
rodeo at the same time so there'll be
Klingons and cowboys like passing each
other what is this but wait a minute so
so there'll be Klingons walking down the
street but also Cowboys but also random
spots now we know that stocks and
Klingons don't get along so that's like
yeah we know that yeah Cowboys and
Klingons get along actually uh Cowboys
and Klingons probably yeah really yeah
yeah
um that would make sense
oh that I know that yeah yeah they've
got that uh bumpy brow
the old bumpy brow so Jill this is
fascinating to me
yeah so Jill you you live here and you
you live there happily do you ever get I
would think people would just get tired
of look at me I'm Spock yeah it's
Thursday enough with the Star Trek you
know or is it or is it okay I don't know
I feel like nobody talks about it and I
honestly know nothing about Star Trek so
it's kind of weird but I just moved here
because my husband grew up here and
just yeah it's it is what it is yeah
well you must really you know what I
gotta say you must really love your
husband that's what's nice I do is that
I do yeah he invited you to basically
join him in a child's bedroom uh yeah
and called it a town
and now it's like you're imprisoned on
the hollow deck or something oh god well
I you know I debated whether I should
say that yeah no you did to us you don't
I did you know what you know what I I
think whenever you say you debated
whether you should say something or not
you always say it never once have you
not said it and I do apologize
well okay so we know now we have a
picture boy do I have a picture of where
you live and I'll be coming to Vulcan I
want you to tell the people I'll be
coming you should bring schlansky here
and do like uh he can go through the
Star Trek Museum and oh my God actually
yeah that's kind of a cool idea right
there's only one flaw I'd have to travel
with Jordan shlansky ah yes the most
annoying person I've ever met